Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Chi è il vero Francesco?
Chi è la vera società?
Chi siamo noi? Chi siete voi?
Questa è la domanda, davvero,
che continua a risuonarmi dentro
sempre, sempre, sempre.
Da lì
- io arrivo da una terra,
da una valle, dalla Valtellina -
da lì ho guardato la natura.
Tutti noi abbiamo sempre
la natura attorno.
E la natura ci si può ispirare.
Ho cominciato a chiedermi, anche,
chi è una vera pianta di mele?
Chi è, cosa fa, una pianta di mele?
Cosa produce una pianta di mele?
E la cosa interessante è che ho capito
che una pianta di mele produce mele,
da un punto di vista umano.
Però, ho anche visto
che se la pianta di mele guarda
la vera essenza della pianta di mele,
la pianta di mele fa anche un'operazione,
che è quella di assorbire
anidride carbonica,
per poi rilasciare ossigeno.
A questo punto,
chi è la vera pianta di mele?
È solo colei che dà delle mele,
oppure è colei che fa, anche,
questa operazione di assorbire
per rilasciare ossigeno?
Chi sono quindi, veramente, io?
Sono qualcuno che lavora
secondo degli schemi sociali,
oppure sono qualcuno
che fa anche qualcosa di più?
Al che, ho cominciato a ragionare
su quelli che sono gli schemi sociali.
E ho cominciato a scoprire una cosa
che per me è super interessante.
Ho cominciato a vedere
che il mondo è pieno di regole rotte.
Delle regole sociali rotte,
delle regole di cooperazione rotte.
Ho cominciato a pensare, quindi,
che le regole rotte dovevano essere rotte.
Quindi ho cominciato a mettermi,
come mantra mio,
il fatto di rompere
le regole che erano rotte.
E quindi, la pianta di mele
non [deve] solo produrre mele,
ma anche produrre ossigeno.
Di fatto, nessuno ha istruito
la pianta di mele a produrre ossigeno,
lo fa da sola.
Quindi, la pianta di mele
sa veramente chi è la vera pianta di mele.
Io, insomma, ci sto un po' pensando
su chi è il vero Francesco.
Poi, nella vita, ognuno di noi
si fa un po' i conti
su quello che gli succede.
Chi va a fare un lavoro,
piuttosto che un altro.
E io mi sono trovato,
in qualche modo, a capire,
a fondare aziende, condurre aziende.
E mi sono trovato sempre
ad essere a capo di qualcosa.
Da lì ho detto:
Ma qual è il vero senso
di quello che facciamo? Dov'è?
Chi siamo, noi?
E guardando le montagne,
ho cominciato a pensare,
mi sono visto come quello
che raccoglieva cuore, a un certo punto,
che è l'ossigeno che viene prodotto.
Guardando le montagne
della mia cara, carissima valle
ho cominciato a dire:
Guardando la cima,
la cima è un po' il posto
di questa montagna
su cui io voglio andare.
È un po' come se fosse il mio obiettivo.
Se voi chiedete a un alpinista
che cosa vuole fare nella vita,
vuole andare in cima
alla montagna per scendere.
A questo punto,
nell'organizzazione, ho detto:
"Qual è l'organizzazione?
Qual è la cima
della nostra organizzazione?
Chi siamo veramente noi?"
Perché siamo un'ottima organizzazione
che produce delle ottime mele.
Non facciamo mele;
però produciamo ottimi servizi,
ottimi prodotti,
il mercato ci riconosce
che siamo molto bravi.
Ma qual è il nostro vero proposito?
Chi siamo noi veramente?
E che cos'è l'organizzazione veramente?
E da lì abbiamo cominciato
a darci collettivamente delle risposte,
e quindi abbiamo cominciato a capire,
a darci un senso, a dare
il senso all'organizzazione,
all'azienda nella quale
tutti noi lavoravamo.
O, come mi piace di più pensare,
all'azienda nella quale
tutti noi serviamo.
Noi siamo servi del nostro vero essere.
Perché noi vogliamo pensare
che cos'è il futuro.
Tanti mi dicono,
"Dovremmo lasciare un futuro migliore".
Dobbiamo lasciare un futuro migliore?
È una domanda?
Secondo me, no.
Secondo me dobbiamo lasciare
un presente migliore,
perché, se ci pensate bene,
tutti noi oggi siamo qua.
Io sono in piedi su questo punto rosso,
voi siete seduti,
e ci troviamo in una condizione
in cui qualcuno domani si risiederà
o ritornerà in piedi su questo palco.
È come se io, in questo momento,
stessi già frequentando
il futuro di qualcun altro.
Ma allora io devo pensare al suo futuro,
e quindi proiettarmi da quella parte,
oppure devo pensare
che questo punto rosso, e la vostra sedia,
in qualche modo deve essere preservata,
deve essere vissuta bene?
E quindi deve essere lasciata,
perché quello è già un futuro in prestito
che avete da qualcun altro.
Allora se io comincio a pensare
che è in prestito da qualcun altro,
comincio a capire che,
come qualsiasi prestito che io ottengo;
vado da una banca
a chiedere dei soldi in prestito,
li devo ridare indietro.
Quindi questo qualcun altro
che arriverà dal futuro
mi darà, dovrò consegnarli il suo futuro,
perché ce l'ho in prestito.
Una banca, generalmente,
mi chiede degli interessi attivi,
e quindi dovrò dare indietro
anche degli interessi attivi.
È questo il senso di quello che devo fare:
quindi non devo costruire
un futuro migliore,
ma devo costruire
un mio presente migliore.
È solo con quell'azione lì
che riconsegno il futuro
di chi verrà dopo di me su questo palco,
di chi verrà dopo di voi su quelle sedie
e chi verrà dopo di noi.
È davvero sistemico.
È sempre un discorso più grande,
di chi arriverà dopo di noi
per trovare il mondo.
Se ci pensate, ci sono grandi artisti,
pensiamo al David di Michelangelo.
Sono opere d'arte che riescono
a resistere centinaia di anni,
e quindi riescono a prendere,
hanno preso in prestito tutto il futuro
e lo stanno riconsegnando.
La magnificenza dell'arte.
Ora pensate come cambia il sistema
se un'azienda comincia a ragionare
con questo termine,
che ha in prestito un futuro.
Pensate alla relazione
che c'è con un cliente.
Consegnate solo delle mele al cliente,
o consegnate anche l'impatto
che andrete a produrre
per costruire quelle mele?
I clienti ti scelgono
anche per quel motivo.
Chiaramente dovete saper fare
delle mele buone al mercato attuale,
quindi non potete far spendere
dieci volte tanto per le mele.
Ma pensate all'azienda:
l'azienda sta servendo,
l'azienda, assieme ai clienti,
stanno servendo un proposito evolutivo.
E quindi cosa fa questa organizzazione?
Questa organizzazione sa perché lavora.
L'organizzazione diventa una piattaforma
nelle quali le persone
si possono sviluppare, evolvere,
possono trovare se stesse.
Questo è il senso di un'organizzazione,
quindi ha senso avere una gerarchia
all'interno dell'organizzazione,
ha senso avere qualcuno
che ti dice cosa tu devi fare?
No, lo sai già.
Perché tu sai che vuoi trasformare CO2
in ossigeno, producendo mele.
Tu sai questo, quindi tu sai
che ti devi muovere in quella direzione,
perché costruirai un impatto su un futuro
che ti è stato dato in prestito.
Quindi un'azienda può essere
auto-organizzata,
un'azienda può essere un organismo vivente
che continua giorno per giorno
ad apprendere e imparare.
Questo è il senso
di quello che sta succedendo.
Questo è il senso di come,
se io riesco a capire
chi sono, chi siamo veramente,
riesco a fare.
E da lì, chiaramente, c'è il consiglio
d'amministrazione di un'azienda.
E che tipo di leadership
deve avere un consiglio?
Pensate: stiamo scendendo
da quella mia montagna,
scendo dalla mia cara valle.
Un amministratore delegato è al servizio
del proposito evolutivo dell'azienda.
Non è il capo.
Il capo è il proposito,
è quello che noi tutti vogliamo fare.
E tutto il resto va al servizio
di questo proposito.
Si parla di servant leadership.
È così, anche il capitale.
Ora, in Italia siamo fortunati,
perché abbiamo le società benefit
che sono lo strumento
che ci permette di fare questo.
Abbiamo una certificazione B-corp, ecc.
Quindi, il punto vero
è che le aziende diventano
dei posti, delle piattaforme
in cui le persone si possono risvegliare,
in cui le persone
possono trovare se stesse,
danno un senso al lavoro,
oltre il compenso.
Il pane lo paghiamo,
quindi il compenso è ragionevole.
È normale, che una pianta
di mele produca mele.
Non mettiamolo in discussione.
Ma il punto importante
è che dobbiamo cominciare a capire
che noi impattiamo nella società,
perché abbiamo un futuro
in prestito da qualcuno.
Quindi, le funzioni
sono tutte le funzioni
di un'organizzazione tradizionale,
e sono all'interno di tutti.
Io sono un po' HR, ufficio del personale;
io sono un po' CFO, finanziario,
io sono un po' di tutte le parti.
È chiaro, se tutti noi
stiamo servendo un proposito
posso condividere con voi
tutte le informazioni
per arrivare a questo proposito.
I salari possono essere trasparenti,
il bilancio mensile
può essere trasparente.
Il budget può essere
a disposizione di tutti,
di tutti quelli che, attraverso l'azienda,
vogliono cambiare il mondo.
Pensate se l'ufficio del personale
è all'interno di ognuno di noi
che assume le persone in un'azienda:
che serve un proposito -
ma fa mele, ricordiamoci, fa mele.
Se io sono in quella condizione,
io cosa voglio?
Io voglio che le persone -
se io volessi assumere qualcuno
che deve lavorare con me,
voglio che quella persona
sfrutti l'azienda
come il luogo
in cui quella persona si può sviluppare.
Quindi chiederei a questa
persona, per prima cosa:
so che tu sai gestire le mele,
so che tu sai potare,
ma voglio anche capire
se tu vuoi veramente venire
a sviluppare te stesso.
Ed è qua, un piccolo pensiero
perché quando si pensa
in maniera imprenditoriale
si comincia a ragionare
e a cominciare a pensare
a che cos'è fare scaling.
Un'azienda deve poter scalare.
Anche l'impatto che produce l'azienda
deve poter scalare,
deve potere andare
e diventare esponenziale.
Tutto questo movimento
delle Exponential Organization,
che dice: "Dobbiamo fare cose".
E la parte importante
che vi voglio dire è:
pensate che dobbiamo trovare un sistema,
e dobbiamo continuare a rompere
delle regole che sono già rotte.
E pensate quando andate a trattare
con un procurement,
con un ufficio acquisti.
Andate a trattare, e l'ufficio acquisti
la prima cosa che vi chiede è uno sconto.
E vi dice: io con voi, però,
voglio avere una relazione
a lungo periodo.
È come se io incontrassi
una bellissima ragazza,
la guardo e dico:
"Io ti voglio sposare, ma puzzi".
(Risate)
E quindi la relazione è strana,
perché io ti voglio sposare
ma, insomma, c'è un problema da fissare.
Ma se è una relazione a lungo termine,
stiamo già trovando una soluzione.
Questo è quello che succede normalmente:
io vado all'ufficio acquisti,
e l'ufficio acquisti mi dice sempre:
"Ah guarda, noi volevamo,
capiamo la tua fornitura,
le tue mail, eccetera eccetera,
però insomma, i tuoi soldi
che mi chiedi, che erano 100,
saranno 80 perché per noi è 80".
Da lì io ho cominciato a pensare:
"Ah cavoli, è dura questa cosa qua,
è come se io volessi stabilire veramente,
una relazione a lungo termine,
ma non ci riesco".
Allora la parte
che ho cominciato a ragionare,
pensandomi parte di un sistema;
tutti noi siamo parte di un sistema,
tutti noi facciamo parte di un sistema.
E se siamo parte del sistema
dobbiamo cominciare a pensare
che, in maniera mutualistica,
dobbiamo aiutare l'altra parte
a far che cosa?
A fidarsi del sistema; e di [con]verso,
anch'io dalla mia parte,
anch'io a fidarmi dell'altra parte.
Quindi arrivare a concepire
che l'altra parte ha ragione.
Quindi la sua quantificazione è giusta.
E quindi il punto è: ci sono due pesi,
due taglie della t-shirt
per lo stesso corpo.
Chi di voi non ha due magliette
di taglie diverse,
però che calzano nello stesso corpo?
Ognuno di noi ce le ha.
Perché? Perché sono due pesi,
due taglie e due pesi,
per lo stesso corpo.
Allora la parte importante,
realizzando questo,
è che anche il nostro cliente ha ragione.
Quindi la sua valutazione
è la sua valutazione,
la sua percezione di valore.
Ah, è super interessante questo argomento,
se comincio a pensarlo, e dico:
"Lo sconto di per sé
era una regola che era rotta".
Perché è normale chiedere lo sconto;
ma perché è normale?
Nessuno lo sa chiedere, è rotto.
Il punto importante, però,
è che quello sconto lì
è un punto sul quale io posso ragionare.
È un punto sul quale io,
assieme al cliente,
posso fare un ragionamento in più,
perché, ricordiamoci,
io voglio espandere l'impatto,
il bene che io voglio produrre
rispetto al mio proposito,
rispetto alla cima della mia montagna.
Quindi cosa posso fare?
Posso trasformare questo concetto
di differenza di prezzo
e costruirla come se fosse una scommessa.
Quando vado al casinò,
e faccio una scommessa
pensando di vincere tutto,
e quindi pensando di prendere
questa scommessa,
questi soldi di differenza,
e dire: "Noi li vogliamo scommettere
per il nostro proposito evolutivo,
perché vogliamo amplificare
il 'chi siamo noi'.
Se ci pensate,
io sono partito da quando avevo 13 anni
a chiedermi chi sono io veramente.
Poi, all'interno dell'organizzazione
in cui ho vissuto,
con i miei colleghi, ho sempre detto:
"Chi siamo noi veramente?"
E a questo punto,
con i clienti e anche i fornitori,
e tutti i portatori di interesse,
ho chiesto: "Ma noi chi siamo veramente?"
Chi siamo e, ancora di più,
qual è il senso del nostro lavoro?
Perché dobbiamo lavorare assieme?
Perché io ti devo fornire le mele?
La cosa interessante è che,
ragionando in questi termini,
anche corporate grandissime
capiscono e dicono:
"Vero, stiamo facendo
qualcosa d'importante".
Quindi puntiamo questi soldi,
come se fosse una scommessa,
e dichiariamo una interdipendenza
tra le due parti.
Quindi dichiariamo che queste due parti
sono tra di loro interdipendenti,
per costruire, o per riconsegnare,
un futuro a qualcuno che verrà.
Per quello che vi dicevo.
E quindi il punto importante
è riuscire a stabilire,
rispetto a una lingua comprensibile,
e siamo nel 2019, ce l'abbiamo -
abbiamo la ESG, abbiamo gli SDG goals,
con i sub-goals, con i target,
abbiamo il mondo
delle Benefit Corporation.
Abbiamo una struttura legale,
di Srl, Sb, Spa, Sp,
che mi permette di dire
che io posso seguire
un proposito evolutivo.
Dichiariamoci per come noi
vogliamo lasciare impatto nel mondo
e andiamo.
Un esempio?
Potremo commissionarci con un cliente,
magari un'assicurazione o una banca,
e dire: "Vedo che tu produci
tanta carta per i tuoi elaborati;
facciamo così, prova a ridurla.
E se tu la riduci,
io questa cifra la scommetto assieme a te
sul fatto che tu riuscirai
a ridurre carta".
Ridurre carta,
per la maggior parte delle volte,
oggi vuol dire tagliare alberi,
vuol dire impattare.
Non li vedo chiaramente gli alberi, qua:
però, se penso a questo futuro
che devo riconsegnare,
magari un giorno li vedrò anch'io,
quegli alberi che avrò segato.
E pensate che cosa interessante
se poi ci aggiungo
anche l'ingrediente legale
e quindi dico:
"Caro cliente, o caro fornitore,
posso fare la stessa cosa,
anche con un fornitore,
su un fornitore
posso andare a creare una,
a chiedere di rendere
le sue persone più felici.
La felicità si misura,
si chiama psicometria.
Quindi io posso fare
delle survey settimanali
per misurare la felicità.
Io posso andare a mettere
queste clausole, questi sconti,
si chiamano sconti condizionati.
È una regola rotta,
lo sconto condizionato, i rebates,
Posso andare, mettere
questo sconto condizionato che dice:
"Caro cliente, caro fornitore,
se non si applica,
se tu non fai azioni
in cui le tue persone sono più felici,
in cui tu tagli, usi meno carta,
perché ti mando il file via PDF,
io ti devo chiedere indietro quei soldi,
perché la scommessa l'abbiamo persa".
E cosa farò di quei soldi?
In maniera assolutamente trasparente,
perché tutti stiamo servendo un proposito,
li userò per ricolmare,
per ridare indietro
quello che stiamo privando
come futuro di chi viene.
Questo lo chiamiamo accordo
di interdipendenza
in cui tutti assieme riconosciamo,
tramite un contratto,
che siamo parti dello stesso sistema.
Con questo, quello che voglio dirvi
è che con le nostre azioni,
se continuiamo a vivere
seguendo le regole,
e non cerchiamo di mettere in discussione,
certe volte, delle regole;
non dico di violarle, dico semplicemente
di rielaborarle, di digerirle,
abbiamo un grandissimo -
lo stomaco è un grandissimo
apparato digerente,
e possiamo veramente essere
dei grandi digestori.
Quindi, se noi non cominciamo
a vedere queste regole,
se noi non cominciamo
a capire che impatto è,
e scalare l'impatto che noi produciamo,
non faremo qualcosa
di efficace per il futuro.
E l'ultimo messaggio
che vi voglio lasciare
è che ognuno di noi, con le sue azioni,
produce impatto e disegna nella sua vita.
L'impatto può essere positivo, neutro
o per me neutralizzante e negativo.
Sta a noi la scelta.
Però ogni volta,
nel momento in cui metto un piede avanti,
produco quell'impatto.
Trovando solo noi stessi,
il modo con il quale noi agiamo,
possiamo dipingere il mondo che vorremo.
E tutti noi stiamo dipingendo.
Namasté.
(Applausi)